consommation de drogues par injection
prise de méthadone et quelques moments
d'amitié voici un nouveau vidéo clip qui
montre de façon frontale le quotidien de
ce coût 10 c'est la vraie vie chez audi
il n'avait pas envie de cacher qu'ils
étaient il cherche pas à faire semblant
de pas avoir de problèmes de
consommation parce que c'est pas pour le
fun qu'ils le font pendant deux ans le
réalisateur michael kemmer a filmé ces
itinérants pour produire le vidéoclip de
la chanson devant les chevaux du groupe
rock montréalais de dm tous qui joue un
peu partout sur la planète
quand j'ai entendu la chanson des vrais
chocs les paroles ça me faisait penser à
tous ces gens n'y a pas de place pour
eux dans la société
[Musique]
la vidéo montre pendant sept minutes la
vie de ces squid j pour arriver à
prendre ces images le réalisateur a
établi un véritable lien de confiance a
vécu il y avait quelque chose en matière
qui est joyeuse
c'était vraiment bon les paroles de la
chanson sont parfois en sourdine pour
qu'on puisse bien entendre les dialogues
pour le batteur du groupe
c'est beaucoup plus qu'un vidéo clip
c'est une histoire c'est un mini film
vidéo de musique en deuxième d'histoire
est beaucoup plus importante que la
musique en février 2010 est le
réalisateur apprend que jake 27 ans son
principal point de contact avec la rue
est mort d'une surdose qu je sais pas
s'il allait continuer je savais pas si
si je pouvais même utilisé ces images de
lui maintenant qu'ils étaient plus là et
finalement avec sa famille et ses amis
tout le monde était d'accord qu'il
fallait lui rendre hommage
même n'a perdu son ami il espère en
avoir fini avec la drogue qu'on sente
plus que ce que signer avec la méthadone
me sens bien tout va bien j'ai changé
beaucoup
ici julie jasmin boudreau radio canada
montréal